buongiorno vanessa oder auch wörtlich
ist wieder einmal war nur bekommt zu
einer neuen folge wie schmeckt noch ein
paar leute aber trotzdem wollen wir
heute die originalen italienischen teile
machen so wie es nur eine richtig
italienische mama machen kann und zwar
ist es in diesem fall die mama von mafia
boss salvatore konnte
das ist spanisch aber wer ist denn
dieser salvatore konnte er spielt eine
rolle in der serie gomorrha auf sky de
moura ist ein italienischen macht ja
serie die auf dem gleichnamigen roman
von roberto saviano basiert diese serie
läuft auf sky und mit sogar von sky
produziert es ist also ein sky original
sowie das original italienische rezept
was für ein zufall gekommen zur werbung
sky bietet nämlich nicht nur 1000 serien
an sondern hat auch eigene produktion
wie zum beispiel gomorrha grenzgänger
britannia und da könnt ihr sogar
entscheiden ob jetzt auf deutsch oder in
der regionalsprache sehen wollt und
vielleicht kann man ja sogar ein
bisschen italienisch lernen
scusi cappuccino ich bin jetzt fast mit
der ersten staffel von gomorrha durch
und kam die serie auf jeden fall
empfehlen sie super spannend und hat so
viele überraschungsmomente mit denen man
überhaupt nicht gerechnet hat und man
taucht echt in die welt der
italienischen mafia familien ein wenn
ihr jetzt lust habt diese serien mal aus
zu checken dann könnt ihr das mit dem
sky ticket entertainment-angebot außer
vorteil es ist auch monatlich können
also wenn ich jetzt euren appetit
angeregt habe versucht dann findet ihr
den link zum angebot unten in der
infobox
und jetzt machen wir mal weiter mit
unser rat feiert hölle hölle tangiert
helle falls ihr euch wundert ja es fällt
mir sehr schwer die ganze diese
italienischen wörter zu sagen es gibt
viele verschiedene arten wie man teile
zubereiten kann
aber man sieht in der szene ganz klar
dass es die promo doro basilico version
ist wie möchten sie ihre tagliatelle pro
modul
basilikum beat du bist wie familie für
mich aber du hast mir den rücken
geschossen bewegt
und das sag ich's meinem outfit sehe ich
jetzt italienisch auch ich muss ja sagen
durch das italienische blut was durch
meine adern fließt bin ich ja ein
fünftel oder so italienerin
das sieht man mir so ein bisschen im
gesicht an und an den haaren
danke papa danke für diese gehen aber
lasst uns aufhören überall haare zu
sprechen und lieber telle aller pomodoro
basilico kochen und für unsere teller
nudeln brauchen wir 75 gramm farina typ
550 drei große eier und salz und mehr
auch nicht und ganz wichtig wir brauchen
eine nudelmaschine die wir uns gerade
frisch gekauft haben und auf die wir uns
sehr freuen weil wir noch nie eine
nudelmaschine benutzt haben
ich liebe dieses format ist erweitert
einfach meinen horizont zuerst mit 275
gramm mehl in eine schüssel tun und dann
kommt unsere prise salz und zum schluss
kam unsere drei eier
barbara okay nicht angeben nummer eins
und nummer drei nach dem ihr eure hände
ordentlich gewaschen habt geht's ans
kneten man kann auch ein bisschen wasser
nach kippen falls der teig zu trocken
ist
was hier wahrscheinlich der fall sein
wird deswegen habe der jenischen frauen
auch so muckis weil sie immer so viel
teig und so treten müssen und deswegen
sind italienischen mammas auf das
oberhaupt der familie weil sie das essen
machen und vom essen machen richtig
stark so unterteilt teig muss jetzt für
eine stunde ruhen und danach können wir
mit unserer nudelmaschine rumspielt
edward said also bis gleich willkommen
es ist jetzt eine stunde vergangen und
wir kümmern uns jetzt um den nudelteig
sie brauchen eine saubere arbeitsfläche
und unserem nudelteig und jetzt kann ich
endlich zum allerersten mal eine
nudelmaschine benutzen ihr lacht aber
ich kann das echt cool mitnehmen den
kann man die nudelmaschine so fest
jetzt fühle ich mich mit beim werken in
der schule ok also dazwischenkommt
wendezeit und dann macht man so an meine
streitfälle und hier könnte ich
spaghetti na super
[Musik]
ok ich finde es okay nehmen wir ein
bisschen teig
ich habe jetzt hier so ein stück machen
wir ein bisschen näher dran es nicht
klebt man jetzt waren wir sind nur über
spiele
ok jetzt haben wir es jetzt machen wir
mal ein bisschen dünner
[Musik]
[Applaus]
endlich kann ich werde gäste da hat
hausgemachte nudeln machen
okay ich habe jetzt einen extrem dünnen
gleichmäßigen teig der sehr gut aussieht
und wir deswegen angst macht wieso
klappt das so gut beim ersten mal ich
habe jetzt gedacht ich fehle ein
bisschen aber etwa shops auch unseren
teil viele aufsatz auch lassen wird ich
mache du dich oh mein gott es tut mir
leid
[Musik]
kommt euch das sind das sind richtige
nur die leute das sind richtig
ok jetzt sagt jeder der schon mal nudeln
gemacht habe das ist auch wenig schwer
und ich glaube auch dass mundl machen
noch ein wenig schwer aber wenn man das
erste mal lud ihn selbst gemacht hat
wenn man seit jahre lang sein ganzes
leben in der packung gegessen hat es
schon ein meilenstein weil ihr könnt
meine nudeln er gar nicht sehen
hier seht ihr meine nudeln so ich mache
jetzt auf den restlichen teig zu nudeln
und dann geht's weiter unsere nudeln
sind jetzt fertig und natürlich brauchen
wir einen topf mit heißem wasser um sie
zu kochen
wir nehmen heute mal den kleinen ein
bisschen seiten das wasser und ja ich
weiss man kann das sah es auch danach
machen während wir warten das wasser
jetzt kocht werden wir schon mal die
soße machen und die ist wirklich einfach
alles was sie dafür brauchen ist zwei
kleine tripolis 250 gramm funkes mit ein
bisschen näher dran eine oder zwei dosen
gestückelte pomodoro das müssen wir noch
schauen ein bisschen olivia und fürs
richtige finish fabiano region bringen
wir das schlimmste hinter uns
zwiebeln schneiden ich hasse beschneiden
wenn wir unsere zwiebeln geschnitten
haben kümmern wir uns um die termine
aber champignons nicht waschen wenn ihr
sie sauber machen wollt dann am besten
abbürsten wenn ihr so ein profi seit wie
ich habe hier natürlich auch keine
bürste deswegen werden wir sehen wenn er
das klappt nicht so glaube ich brauche
ein küchentuch sind schon extrem
dreckige job machen warum klippen da so
viel erde tragen wie bin und paprika
sind jetzt geschnittene zwiebeln und
paprika paprika paprika sind jetzt
geschnitten und jetzt kommt alles in
einen topf und die champignon das ist
jetzt unsere mission so unser wasser
kocht jetzt und jetzt können die nudeln
die nudeln sind im topf kochen und in
der zeit machen unsere soße weiter mit
gestückelten tomaten die soße sieht
schonmal gut aus natürlich müssen wir
jetzt mit salz und pfeffer würzen
ein bisschen süße darf auch nicht fehlen
und wir sind eine moderne italienische
mama die agaven dicksaft stadt sogar ein
bisschen oregano macht jedes
italienische gericht noch ein bisschen
besser
zwischenstand lecker und wie sieht's mit
unseren nudeln aus wir brauchen noch
frederico
einander nahe dass es jetzt werte hier
sind es mehr aufdecken
hier haben wir einmal unsere teller und
unsere soße ich werde jetzt die
tagliatelle einmal durch die soße wippen
und dann auf dem teller machen weil die
italiener essen ja nicht so viel soße
wie die deutschen
die machen da nur so ein mantel um die
nudeln herum
ja es sollte nicht so mit meinem
halbwissen umherschweifen sohn ist doch
das wichtigste was man dort in der szene
ganz genau sie frische basilikumblätter
wichtig parmesan der probiert natürlich
parmesan reiben
jetzt stellen wir uns natürlich wieder
die allerwichtigsten frage wie schmecken
die teile aus dem original italienisches
mamas rezept guten appetit
wow das ist absolut lich mitgekauft nur
den zu vergleichen
das ist auf jeden fall ein gericht was
ich machen werde wenn ich gäste habe und
wirklich angeben möchte wartet leute ich
wohl kurz mal eine nudelmaschine raus
oder vielleicht führen serienabend
selbst gemachte nudeln und jetzt ist das
video leider auch schon zu ende
doch bevor ihr geht holt euch doch das
geld entertainment-angebot unten in der
infobox findet ihr den link und ich
hoffe natürlich wie immer euch hat die
folge gefallen wenn ihr weitere
rezeptvorschläge habt aus filmen oder
sie
ab damit in die kommentare ich freue
mich jedes mal wieder und ich muss sagen
diese nudeln waren wirklich absolut
spitze eine absolute empfehlung macht
meinen nudeln selbst zu hause wenn ihr
keine nudelmaschine habe ich habe sie
jetzt bei amazon gekauft für 50 euro das
ist schon teuer aber ich glaube es wird
sich lohnen weil ich definitiv jetzt
öfter nudeln machen werde
ich packe ich den link auch unten rein
und ansonsten würde ich sagen dass wir
uns beim nächsten mal wieder sehen
hau dir ein oder wie man auf italienisch
sagt arrivederci